I came home from college One Summer and
we had a home invasion
now these two drug addicts broke into my
parents house
and I was like this is my time this is
my fun this is what I've lived my whole
life for I grabbed uh Remington shotgun
shirtless guys just running around the
house cutting wires off of TVs throwing
them into their car moving in and out
and I grabbed this shotgun I loaded it
up I felt it and I brought it up the
stairs and I saw these guys my mom had
had neck surgery my dad was taking care
of her they were on the other side of
the house
and I just thought
you you're gonna you're gonna murder
these guys you're gonna kill these guys
and everyone's gonna have to move out of
the house
no everyone's gonna look at you
differently
and what I was really doing was just
buying time